boys we're gonna chat a little bit about
fable legends yesterday was announced
that the game has been cancelled after
four years of development and Microsoft
is looking into possibly closing
lionhead studios in the UK they can't
just shutters like a company they
actually have to take 30 days to see if
it's a reasonable decision but for all
intents and purposes it seems like fable
legends is definitely gone maybe the
series done and probably lionhead
studios as well I'm very curious about
how you guys feel about this game tying
played a lot of fable at least one
through three how do you feel about them
sort of taking a game like that that
people know and is sort of defined what
it is and turning it into this this odd
like multiplayer free to play game do
you think they're risking the series by
doing that I mean it seems to have ended
up that way I think fable three rub so
many people the wrong way yeah I thought
this game was doomed from the start I
mean I i just i don't know if you guys
played three but it was probably the the
lowest point in that series guy and I
think maybe they were trying to do
something different with doing this
whole like free to play four player
co-op thing I mean that it's weird cuz
wasn't the beta is supposed to be like
next month or something don't realign
going it's been going they're gonna keep
it open until April okay got it yeah
yeah I never I I I either outgrew fable
games or I just kind of lost interest
after 3i love I think too was the
pinnacle of that series i love to i
think they did so many unique changes
from the first one um i love my dog i
still have dreams right here like you're
brewing beer and just hear this guy go
the perfect pint but 1,500 times
leggings were that is defeated non stop
I mean just brewing beer that guy just
telling me how great of a job I did but
um but yeah I I don't know I mean I I
don't know much about fable legends I've
obviously seen gameplay I know was
announced you know three years ago and I
kind of haven't heard anything since I
just don't think the buzz was there yeah
it's not a fitting like I said that they
had that what mala news twitter account
was hacked like what two weeks ago
saying he's retired i think this is kind
of oddly it funny if it's still
technically in open beta is that doesn't
mean the project scanned
oh the project you can see it's gone
they're doing is higher at a goodwill oh
ok so the people who are looking forward
to it who had put time into it Wow now
like you get to play till April and
that's it cheese yeah creative director
David Eckelberry speaking to Kotaku back
2015 he was talking about you know how
can they make this game viable given
that it's free to play and they were
trying to avoid sort of the the shifty
practices that make a lot of free to
play games money yeah um he said we need
scale pc gives us that scale element but
even with the core xbox audience we've
got a lot to work with we need millions
probably but then the fable series has
always hit those numbers yeah is it safe
to assume that a company can just play
with a series do whatever they want with
it and expect to get the same sales game
after game no I mean I think I just if
anything you learned it they were just
too late on this I mean now when you
have like all these mobos come now me
and think about like you have battleborn
battlecry a Paragon smite you have I
mean that was a big craze right that
happened over the last three years or
four years yeah and then meanwhile
there's like this four player co-op like
yeah free to place like rotating heroes
it sounded yeah and you could I think
they're just late and I and I think that
the audience I don't know me again like
I'm a little older than you guys so
maybe I'm just the old fart who just as
tired of for you are not no idea at this
point but I think that um I think it's I
I think they took a gamble I don't
actually criticize him for taking a
gamble but I don't think it paid off and
it's clear and showing and that's
probably why is lion heads being
disbanded it's gone well so that's the
thing is that they have a month to
justify the fact but they want a
clothesline what's the other studio that
was working on there was a press play or
press play was yeah I don't know if they
were working on fable legends it work on
another get there a part of the sort of
shuttering that's happening right now
got it over there yeah yeah that was the
yeah I just know that they may have
taken one too many risks they may have
not had the playerbase like you know
when i was in game dev we when you make
a game you you have two especially in a
beta you have to get all those players
to come in and if they don't stick
around you don't offer anything unique I
imagine they were going to go with like
cosmetic items to be more of like the
the pay structure and that's how you get
like returning people that come and
spend money but maybe just wasn't
happening do you guys think the fable
series is done
and furthermore can Microsoft risk
having one less exclusive series under
their belt nothing's ever done Peter no
yeah ten years to come back and reboot
this entire thing you wish I I have a
feeling i mean that's that's kind of
like the creator's mantra right look at
Hollywood look at gaming they had to
reboot it like 10 years later I often do
things like this get cancelled like so
late in development when they had a fan
base like like you know people who
really like fable have been watching
this game for years nothing for and now
Microsoft is basically saying sorry yeah
I don't know if they can really come
back from this it seems like that's
that's sort of put themselves they dug a
little bit of a dish it'd be it'd be I
don't I can't really think of any other
examples where this has happened before
really and someone's come back so maybe
you're right did the game look promising
like legends we're like what was the
response of like that game as a whole
people so I was reading some previews
this morning people seem to enjoy sort
of the eastern metrical aspect so for
people would play just like a hero's
right yeah and then a different player a
fifth player would play the villain sort
of like a dungeon master like in
Dungeons and Dragons gets to define like
where traps are where enemies are and
stuff like that and people made it sound
like look we've got the fable dressing
and environment but we have this new
gameplay where you get to play you know
one of your friends gets to play a
villain a little bit like evolved in
that regard I was going to say that it
looks like they just followed the same
path that evolved in weho crap yeah I
mean it's possible they got a lot of
negative feedback from the beta but um I
guess we'll never know yeah i mean as
someone who's only played like a little
bit of the first 1i that would not be an
incentive to go back like my incentive
for a fable game would be like let me
play catch-up and and and see why people
love the lower that the story of it
likes so I mean you hear such praise for
like yeah two and one like I'd like to
see that how did you know in another
form sorry to interrupt how did the
they've release the original was
released like wait last year like the HD
remaster if you write again did that do
well like the anniversary edition did it
do okay I know we I looked at it it
looked great yeah I just wasn't sure if
it was doing well I'm not quite sure I
mean it seems to me that's sort of like
one of those timeless games it gets a
bit of a facelift right yeah but people
still I think are kind of burned from
three especially like talking to you it
sounds like the series at that point
lost relevance yeah I just think that I
mean
it was weird because had I mean that I
can see what they were trying to do with
like adding more political themes and
then you like kind of becoming king and
defending your kingdom against invaders
and stuff and it just too was maybe two
is just so good this is so good they're
like crap what do we do like do we just
expand upon that I don't know I mean you
kind of see that right with like
existing games I mean how iterative is
Zelda really you know it's kind of the
same story you know like they're
obviously are some different games like
winwaker and Skyward Sword are a little
different they look different but yeah
for the most part that formula still
there right i mean do you maybe fable
went too far I just don't know I just
member like to was amazing because you
just they really expanded upon one they
perfected everything you obvious it
perfected perfected I would say they
perfected everything everyone yeah you
could I mean like everything you did
affected your character you could drink
and eat pies and just get fat or you
could eat celery and get like really
thin just like real life yeah it's
exactly real you know you could marry
you could marry people you had same-sex
marriage you could [ __ ] a hooker you
know that's some language yeah hold the
phone I'm sure they're laughing back
there yeah I know anyways the whole
thing in you know if you didn't wear a
condom you could get a disease oh well
you're sterile way there were condoms
there were condoms available to rabbit
skin she was about that I just know that
if you didn't wear one and you had sex
with a prostitute chances are you'd have
gotten like an STD or you could get
sterile or you could get her knocked up
and then you have a kid and the kid
could die and there's no those weird
some yeah I mean it was so cool again
just like real life exactly so cool you
can get diseases and if you were evil
you can grow horns remember that too
like i do remember hearing i think your
dog would actually mad a dog that was
the best part about fable to the dog is
the second time you talked about it so
unless a dog is great yeah because you
if you're a good character the dog will
get like you'll turn Lycans like a
golden retriever but if you're kind of
like corrupt and bad it just turns black
as I'd like a nice like a flat co
terrier or something like that it's
weird and then I think there are even
some DLC expands so you could actually
change the kind of dog you had like a
bloodhound or Dalmatian or husky or
something so that I I remember all that
remember three not liking it all because
I don't didn't have another of at a dog
I just remember not liking it because it
just it wasn't as fun and there were so
many you were you were ruling the
kingdom I could see where they were
trying to go but at the same time I felt
that there was a lack of they I think
they just lost their way at some point
and it was almost kind like you were
managing a kingdom and then you know it
got so we're just like I just like taxes
and people yelling at me and I'm just
I'm done I mean yeah they seem like like
significantly different games like and I
guess that's where like my opinion
having not really the delve into these
but what what's the game I would look
forward to i don't know like it sounds
like 22 but yeah I mean up like a MOBA
fabled mova that's that's not like a
completely different game yeah like just
like as you said just like pulling the
name you know I know how experimental do
you get I mean before you start taking
chances it's kind of it's it's hard
right because you want to bring new
friends into the fray right but then you
want to also please the existing ones
you have I don't know if that might have
been why they had problems well you see
a game like halo wars which like people
have played it seemed to really like it
yeah but it doesn't reach the same sales
as regular halo no right but but this is
a free-to-play game so maybe I just in
were their transactions during the beta
I doubt it right I doubt it yeah so well
either way it is sad for fans of the
series that the game is cancelled and
unfortunately for lionhead studios
employees that might be losing jobs so
not to make light of the situation it
sucks and if you're looking forward to
fable legends let us know in the
comments below and if you have any great
memories share those as well
you